[Music]
each week Sky News speaks to hundreds of
people people from all walks of life
presidents prime ministers business
leaders celebrities ordinary people with
extraordinary stories to tell here are
some of the stories they've told us over
the last year we don't have to live with
being raped when we think we're going to
a business meeting do you feel you've
got a reputation that is fear no no I'm
his soft room I'm just hoping that my
house wasn't gonna get destroyed guests
could have had other plans
my message to President Trump these are
children and we need to take action we
be witnessing it for actually decades
but it's getting worse and it's
accelerating having a career this long
and not having to do panto it's
incredible yes yes okay good sky nations
congratulations on the purchase
[Music]
Harvey Weinstein is the mogul who once
ruled Hollywood in 2011
Melissa Thompson visited his offices
here in New York to pitch him a business
idea for her tech startup company as
part of the demo that then
twenty-eight-year-old recorded what
happened a few hours later she says
Weinstein raped her in a hotel room
Melissa agreed to talk to me about that
video I was thinking okay he's hugging
me what what do I do now
I was sensing I have to be a little bit
more vigilant of this situation than I
originally thought every time that he
toed the line of being inappropriate
enough where I may have said something
he could sense it and he pulled he
pulled back and he changed a dynamic
again and so he's going from almost
pulling a trigger on using this platform
to then he put his hand up under the
table up my dress I was trying to save
face but at first I was trying to kind
of manage the situation there was a
combination of confidence and a naivety
that led me to you know this dynamic
that we see now I tried to keep it on
script in terms of pitching him the
product but I still touched you on the
shoulder he was still touching me on
stranger your head as that's happening I
what do i do how did I get myself here I
lost my train of thought and I was
trying so hard to to gain back my own
mental footing at some point his his
whole effect changed and and he looked
like a predator he is his eyes became
dark what would you say to someone who
might watch that and say well I mean I
was flirting with him is that what you
see when you watch it it was more tricky
than
I think it's possible to judge from
looking at it I've worked on Wall Street
before I went to business school and I
worked in an environment that was
heavily male-dominated I thought I could
handle it I had never met any one that I
couldn't handle until Harvey Weinstein
had people been more vocal and not said
yeah that's Harvey or yeah we have to
live with that you don't we don't have
to live with things that are illegal and
abusive and and we don't have to live we
don't have to live with being raped when
we think we're going to a business
meeting
Weinstein denies all non-consensual
sexual contact in a statement Harvey
Weinstein's lawyer Benjamin Brafman said
several respected journalists and
trustworthy individuals have seen the
entire video the video when viewed in
its entirety in context and not in
select excerpts demonstrates that there
is nothing forceful but casual if not
awkward flirting from both parties
anything short of that is intended to
make mr. Weinstein appear inappropriate
and even exploitative it was produced by
miss Thompson to bolster her position in
a civil lawsuit seeking money this is a
further attempt to publicly disgrace mr.
Weinstein for financial gain and we will
not stand for it
facts do matter
it started when a father and daughter
were taken ill in a small English city
it ended as a major diplomatic incident
between the west and Russia Sergey and
Yulia sky fell survived being poisoned
with the chemical weapon Navi chalk dawn
Sturgis was not so lucky she died after
coming into contact with it
her partner Charlie Rowley was also
poisoned but survived he spoke to me
about it
give me a sense of how you're feeling
now horrified shocked the whole ordeal I
can't believe this happened
how's your thought process changed since
you've been out coming to terms with
what's happened
not really I can't I can't say so really
how are you physically now physically
any stronger mentally and physically
yeah just lay by day thank you
step in step by step this is distant
quite a lot to take him you know I feel
terrible when Dawn's parents you know as
children what they're going to go
through how are you coping with the
death of dawn yeah it's a struggle just
a really lovely person a loving caring
do anything for anyone made plans maybe
hoping to have a future together
she's moving to the area in Amesbury
very thing russia's intelligence service
the GRU was blamed for the Salisbury
attack I asked the former head of mi6
for his assessment of the threat that
Russia poses
well it does look like a rather
incompetent operation and an operation
which you knew was probably not
sufficiently well-prepared if they had a
specific objective yes I mean it's a
damages their reputation but you know
the giu is big powerful well-funded
organization and you know we shouldn't
underestimate the problems that they can
still cause even when they've had a
significant setback and of course it
what it does also do is underline it's a
threat to the UK from Russia and do you
think that more needs to be done to
combat that threat from Russia because
it does feel as if you know little has
changed really we're no longer in the
Cold War and I don't see that the threat
that Russia presents now is equivalent
to the situation that we had during the
Cold War
however a Russian espionage Soviet
espionage has never stopped it's deeply
embedded in Russia's DNA Russia
historically has always used
assassination as a weapon it's part of
the Russian political DNA it's wrong a
terrible thing to say
but it's a violent country and they tend
to kill each other
lava from the Kilauea volcano erupting
on Hawaii's Big Island is exploding as
it pours into the ocean shooting out
poisonous gases with fragments of rock
inland molten rock is burning through
jungle and destroying everything in its
path that includes the homes of some of
the islands residents you ready to go
I'm ready I have already vacua today I
just came down to say goodbye to my
neighborhood last time when you know
everybody on this road you're like a
family you know and just
did you expect it to ever get this bad
no not really I didn't know what to
expect but I was hoping that my house
wasn't gonna get destroyed I guess God
had other plans
we're going back quickly now because the
fish is opening up let's go
it is tragic and in another way it's
really beautiful because it's it's
absolute destruction and creation at the
same time it was a rescue operation
which inspired the world's divers
navigating narrow tunnels to free 12
boys and their football coach trapped in
a flooded cave
in Thailand the group was stranded
underground for nearly three weeks
during which time I spoke to some of
their friends and families the choir mmm
God wouldn't a manic alert look lower
they you were stopped on here don't you
call dule dule look low and I'm talking
the entire album hey Mon young with
employers hey old man you die tomorrow
how are you now you saw how they cope
you are near ha ha - you remain communal
aha dilute Luka how panicky Lana Lang
Ottawa Anthony got a long time from our
cannula ha ha 34 - Jennifer
oh yeah oh my my 19 Hardy gun Allah they
got some markup coming a guy from laying
up [ __ ] they so I'm for damn at home I
really have ling-ling have been gone
Vincent Zimbabwe is president elected
promised free and fair elections that
would sure the wild Zimbabwe had changed
the questions about its conduct the
display of violence that follows left
many wondering if the man once called
the crocodile please break from the
corruption in the past
Alex Crawford from Sky News in a
democracy people are allowed to say what
they want but when you look to
practicality then one must be objective
and it is true that the campaign was
real until with each the elections which
again was conducted totally free what
about the army because there's lots of
rumors that you're not getting on with
your vice president the former army
chief and that many people would want me
and Vesper not to be in good books
unfortunately they will dream any dream
and it's not
no one can build your own against dreams
let those people continue to dream me
and my brother are friends not only now
but throughout the liberation war but
you feel you have control total control
if he is an area I think I'm not in
control can you tell me so I the correct
it because I'm satisfied I am in full
bobak Defense Forces your nickname is
the crocodile right which sounds scary I
mean they're not many friendly
crocodiles do you feel you've got a
reputation that is feared no no no I'm
his soft as wool nearly 200 countries
have agreed rules for tackling climate
change it came at the end of a
conference in Poland which was addressed
by Sir David Attenborough I asked him
for his thoughts about the risks to the
planet that they are real people
involved and these are real issues in
the in the West the comfortable West and
particularly wealthier part of the
comfortable of the West
you know we're buffered from these
things and we may well say to wonder
well it doesn't really matter whether we
lose the light on it doesn't really
matter whether we stop maybe whether we
go on eating meat because we're not
affected but in fact it does matter
because it matches the whole world and
there are the first people to feel the
consequences of course are the poor
there are those at the bottom of the
heap are those who are really and
they're vulnerable to what is happening
in the time and that's why the whole
world together should actually act on
their behalf the used to be said that it
would be our children or our
grandchildren even who would feel the
effects of climate change do you get the
sense now from what you're seeing but
it's our generation that is already
beginning to see the planet change
oh yeah there's no doubt about that
I mean the forest fires the
desertification now Africa of course
will already be we've been actually
witnessing it had we been aware of it
for actually decades but it's getting
worse and it's accelerating that's why
somebody has to be done
what are you for the Royals a new Prince
a 70th birthday it's rather like
indigestion many happy returns not quite
the same things you get okay over seas
tours a handover of responsibilities
plus not one but two royal weddings and
a new Star Trek we enjoyed talking we
had lots in common and because we we had
an instant connection that said earlier
we we got on really well and we did we
did develop a friendship Megan and I
were at lunch and she was really excited
that day at lunch and I said sure she
was in London and I said you look
fantastic Megan what's what's going on
in your life you seem excited
she said well yes I have a date tonight
and I said really with whom do I know
him and she said yes I'm sure you know
him I meet
and in a whisper she sort of said and I
said and she said Prince Harry I'm
meeting Prince Harry tonight I said
Prince Harry and we had a discussion and
we said I saved him like God how
wonderful and how exciting and do you
know what you're getting yourself into
and we discussed it and you know
continue with the conversation over
lunch and so that was it I and I knew of
course knowing Megan I knew that Terry
would be fascinated with that from the
hills of Hollywood's to the streets of
Soho we've heard from some of the
world's best known stars award-winning
actors the biggest names in music and
global icons tell me about this award
what does it mean to you it means
everything to me it's it's you know not
not only is it a British the British
Academy but to be back in my hometown
and win this and you know to win it for
playing the quintessential British icon
it's beautiful yeah it's a beautiful
thing
[Music]
it was really beyond fun I've never been
on a movie that had less tension and I
wasn't sure what the reason was except
all is such a great director everyone
was so friendly
absolutely because because that's who I
am
[Music]
1989 mill stood in a room and looked at
one another and thought what the hell am
I doing here sometimes it feels like 30
years sometimes it feels like 50 and
then other times it just feels like
seconds yesterday it makes me really
proud being in the entertainment
industry like we are and having a career
this long and not having to DuPont oh
it's incredible yes are you going back
and watching loads of old footage
because some of them are classics aren't
they I mean some of the moves that you
busted especially you get likes wasted
we could have cut out at least 75% of
everything that but the thing is because
of that that's why people come to the
show
when known I say we in our massive shows
is the dedication that people want and
people see in the entertainment value
that being said I think we could have
done 75% let's move it
not a few more days off
[Music]
I just felt in some small way if we
could just bring them back just once
more it's to lay them on the ground of
this country once more it's something
really worth it it was just about
physical izing that number and creating
a figure for every one of those nines
and it was so important that it was
actually each figure is associated with
a name as I would as I'd make a figure
it would be crossed off cost of a great
volumes of books I've got and that was
so vitally important that these that
these weren't just a collection of of
images they are actually representing an
individual tell me where are we well
this is where I store some of the
figures and this is where I've worked
for several years down here which is
it's it's quite quite a place
it really is it's amazing to be in their
company some odd thing to say but it as
a sense of perspective it's like it's
like nothing else I always read the name
aloud when I cross it off I always read
the name aloud which is important just
for one more time it's very overwhelming
being
in here yeah it gets me every time
this was a world war it's enough to say
if there's a world war for a young for
anyone you can't get your head around
that you just cannot get your head
around the degree of suffering that went
on so the only thing I think is is to
tell stories personal stories now they
can be true they can be about your great
uncle your great great grandfather or
you can do what I do use you base it on
trees and then take it a stage further
and you make fictional it and there's a
different kind of truth in addiction and
what's good about that is the child can
then identify with the soldier because
otherwise all those soldiers out there
now and they're all gone anyone who
knows them what will news them is gone
as well so effectively they're all
unknown soldiers now but all unknowns
over so you're anyway to get to know one
is to know a story
what does the poppy mean to you my uncle
Peter was killed at age 21 in the RAF in
the second world war so to me he was a
photograph on a mantelpiece and nothing
wrong and but you know when you're young
and you see your mother cry well you
don't forget it and my mother was not a
crying woman generally a talk but on
November the 11th Ananda uncle Peters
birthday she was we're going to do a
huge sand painting of one of the
characters in it and on the on folksmen
Beach you will be a wolfred Owen on
other beaches it will be other people
who have a connection with a community
near them at low tide the sang will be
ruched into a portrait and it's
extraordinary what happens you've no
idea what you're doing is you're doing
it and then when you get up on a cliff
top 400 AD wrong camera or a helicopter
you can see this beautiful image of a
person who stood on these beaches if you
like and obviously when the tide returns
it washes them away and is that a final
goodbye I don't know it's a hundred
years it's a question for the country to
ask it seems like a moment that you
could stop celebrating the first world
war that was my opinion certainly when I
began this process it's not my opinion
now
[Music]
growing humanitarian disaster is
unfolding in Indonesia tonight as the
scale of Friday's earthquake becomes
clear Suri auntie's husband is dead she
brings us back to potato the place that
used to be her home where the village
once stood is now a muddy wasteland
so the house here and all houses here
here hundreds of people are moving a
contour going on Tana transitivity by
the Lumpur lorry
tsumo kunavaram trad selamatkan we are
bombarded and Sasha Virginia they are
iridophores versa to lumbar
Yuni cetera Papa country so Africa da da
da dinkles I am doing another SIA
[Music]
[Music]
this community used to contain some of
the most glamorous mansions in America
if you look around now and it is all
just smokin ash a lot of normal people
live here as well it's a tragedy that
[Music]
was locked on ran across the way the
house is going up right down below every
house is going up my aunt's house who
lives a couple doors down her house been
there since the fifties burnt down in
the ground
I always swore I'd never lose but when
that house across the street was going
out
it was a rough night seen flames coming
up it was really scary and you know
there's five kids in the car and a
one-year-old that's screaming and crying
because he doesn't want to be in a car
seat and other kids going are we okay
and I'm just trying to like act like
yeah we're fine
yeah but I'm like wondering if we're
gonna die there's a lot of people up
there they didn't have time but do you
know nothing this is 6:30 in the morning
started by 8:30
it's engulfing paradise these people
weren't even licked yet you know and
they're back in the woods and you know I
just like hear the word for and it just
[Music]
the tragedy there's a lot of mass
casualty it's sad it's very sad
we're trying to get people out of here
and we're stuck there's nothing we were
at gridlock and cars ain't moving and I
just it's the worst feeling ever
these people aren't getting out and
they're not traffic's not moving it was
it's hard
it's very devastating brexit means
breakfast breakfast brexit brexit breaks
its brexit brexit brexit means brexit
it's not often that you get to interview
the leader of one of her two main
political parties but in November I
spoke to both of them on the same day I
am interested in the impact it's had on
you personally because some of the
language we've heard some of the
enormous briefings in recent weeks have
been frankly pretty horrific we've heard
talk of killing zones of nooses of
assassinations I mean how does that make
you feel well first of all I I think all
of us in politics have a responsibility
to make sure that when we talk about
things we do so responsibly and we think
about the sort of terminology in the
language that we're using but look it
doesn't it doesn't distract me from the
main task at hand and that's why I come
it's the well look father
politics is a tough business and I've
been in a long time do you feel sorry
for the Prime Minister a politics is
full of lots of thrills and spills there
is a quite big difference between labour
and conservative parties in that labour
is largely a member led organisation and
my mandate came from party members and I
appealed to them in 2016 and gained an
increased level of support
I don't do personal attacks and a
personal abuse you never said nothing
personal in criticism I do understand
what people go through and I understand
all of that but I do also understand the
responsibility of Parliament and
government to deliver for the people
that have put us there in the first
place I was watching Sky News doing
three hours yesterday I am very sad
today because seeing the United Kingdom
which is not something less than
important seeing the United Kingdom even
opinion is a moment of sadness it's not
a moment of celebration if you are
British citizen watching this now this
morning would you tell them that this is
a good deal that there is nothing else
on offer this is the best deal we could
have achieved
if I was a British agent I would be
deeply sad when imagining the life of my
grandchildren
every morning sunrise starts your day
with the top story expert analysis
informed conversation incisive debate
you concentrate don't let us down gotta
stop ready that's why it's so exciting
to have you here in the flesh in the
studio I can't believe we have funny
thing how do you keep yourself looking
so young and you work out well anybody
who thinks I've had a facelift are
talking about the Botox every day I just
sit that work out when I'm gonna have me
breakfast and I've seen what you've got
in your sky canteen and it's fantastic
what is the chest version of Armageddon
that we could see today mail so what
happens is that if they draw their games
played at 25 minutes each and they go
next for 10 seconds every time they move
this is the Royal opus by the way this
man definitely has played before then or
gone have touched it as well so there
you go
yep fresh if you run out of live TV if
those games are still drawn at 25
minutes per move then they go to five
minutes each which is what we've got
right now if that fails if those games
are still a drawer if it's still level
then we play Armageddon now in
Armageddon white gets five minutes black
gets four minutes but white has to win
so now if the games are draw black wait
so there's got to be a result in the
Armageddon game now ladies and gentlemen
I'm about to take Neil's Queen oh you
are yeah I think we could maybe be back
and start again gotta say Robert you're
a chip off the old block very much so
just every day more I remember I was
going through some old photos and I got
a photograph out and said what do you
think of this and he goes that's a photo
of me
no it's not it's a young dad photo yeah
what's interesting though is that it's
obviously we knew what Steve did and and
and his passion for nature what we
didn't realize at the time necessarily
was how that was a family wide sort of
venture yes no he was definitely larger
than life and we're very proud to be
carrying on with what he started it's
sure what's so special is that everyone
dad was the ultimate wildlife warrior
but to us he was the greatest dad and to
be able to carry on in his footsteps and
make sure that his legacy lives on
forever is such a blessing I'm a hundred
percent addicted to my phone but I am my
mom is my dad is everyone around me is
really addicted their phone whatever you
like to admit it or not we're just so
used to scrolling and filling that time
out with with our phone and our
smartphones but you know Instagram
completely changed my life like it
allowed me to connect with millions of
people it allowed me to reach people all
over the world with my mission which is
to inspire you to cook a healthy recipe
or do a workout so I think if I started
today though with the same kind of
motivation the same videos I wouldn't
have the success because when I started
it was like just you know just starting
up not ever we're doing it was now
there's so many people doing recipes and
fitness and online plans that I think I
had a good idea at the right time so I
got lucky with the timing
[Music]
after decades of hostility between their
countries came a meeting which shocked
the world u.s. President Donald Trump
holding talks with North Korea's leader
Kim Jong but behind the pomp and
ceremony are real people with real lives
I spoke to two sisters who defected from
North Korea to the South they told of
the challenges they faced and for their
own protection chose to remain anonymous
what happened to people who opposed the
regime phenomena said I'm a
synchronicity between Kadesh me and
similarities ya sadati as'habi us a
common back o more cotton serum sells
what in the current economy
today's capital necessary how much in
German Cancer Centre audience of
calendar cancer a parent and a oxi be
Western young democratic own cop Tony
so did you ever think you'd be riding
the subway and so
Toto Saigon weather style
and I saw to internal tagging you in my
sip down corner to mints on there can
you wear what you want in North Korea is
it controlled well as they were huge and
I love to wear tight pants still never
seen anything like this so my clothes
would be totally out people here win
Kotani top is okay on the 14th of
February Valentine's Day teenager
Nicholas Cruz walked into his former
school in Florida and shot 17 people
dead in the aftermath I traveled to
Stoneman Douglas High School in parkland
and spoke to David holger student now
turned activist who survived the
shooting we'd heard rumors from teachers
and students that we were gonna have a
Code Red drill that was very realistic
and sadly this was not but good thing we
took it seriously because if we didn't
we may have died and when did you
realize that it was not the drill that
you thought it was you realized this was
not a drill when we actually started
seeing the headlines on our phones
because everybody was looking it up and
when we started seeing that that's when
I decided to start recording because I
didn't know whether or not I would make
it out of it or whether or not any of us
would but I knew if I didn't what would
survive was the voices of the people
that I interviewed and I asked them how
they felt in that situation because I
knew that I never wanted anybody to go
through this again and nobody should
ever especially a high schooler anyone
no one should ever have to go through
something like this and what I asked
them was how do you feel so that if we
died our voices we got go on do you
think there is a surge of determination
now amongst young people here to get
something done I certainly hope so but
if that's only here it's not gonna be
enough
what we need is young individuals out
there and we need the entire country of
America to start getting out and being
politically active this is country run
by popular sovereignty and with that the
pupil have the most power but when the
people don't say what they want and when
they don't make their voices heard the
government because
just an overseer and it starts abusing
its power and that's what we're really
seeing here because politicians can make
all the promises they want and they can
give all their condolences but at what
point do we say that's not enough and we
call for action eyes I think this is
that point because we've seen far too
many of these mass shootings
these are children my message to
President Trump would be acknowledge
this don't let this be another mass
shooting this is an event that needs to
be a turning point and it's event that
nobody should ever have to go through
you have children yourself sir
realize the true gravity of the
situation these are children and we need
to take action
what a year in sports a
better-than-expected Russia World Cup
for England excitement in rugby success
in cricket a memorable Winter Olympics
and inspiring stories from a host of
other sports in a moment we'll hear from
boxing champion Anthony Joshua and from
a retiring England captain and not one
but two British winners of the
tournaments
but first the inspiring story of Billy
manga the teenage racing driver who lost
his legs in a crash in 2017 but he's
back behind the wheel I was racing in
British f4 a second round of the
championship at Donington Park and
unfortunately had an accident a
stationary car spun off up ahead on the
road ahead and I had two very other cars
in front of me that I was battling for
position with and then as they saw the
car last minute and dive out away I was
sort of just presented with this car in
front of me that I hit about 120 mile an
hour and here that was kind of it do you
remember what's the next thing you
remember so I was awake in the car after
the accident so I remember sort of the
doctors been around me and kind of the
whole process of me being put to sleep
and stuff of that and then I can't
remember sort of the next three days
after the accident what had happened in
that three days while you were in a coma
I said yeah so yeah essentially because
of the extent of the damage done to my
legs they had to amputate my my right
leg below the knee and my left leg just
above the knee
so yeah I've seen a double amputations
it was the journey back to even thinking
about getting into a car again it's a
long journey and it's taken it's taken a
while although it feels like it was only
a few weeks ago the accident the arrow
spin it's been tough and lovely it's
been a lot of hard work behind the
scenes from from me and all the guys at
Carla and the team that of running
within British every in this year to get
the controls ready so I can actually
compete oh yeah I'm glad to say on back
out I'm gonna clean up Lee I live right
I train hard and that's the way the
sport should be it's fair competition
that way you know I'm coming from this
game is hard enough as it is
you don't want no drug cheats compete
you move you because it's tough enough
as it is so yeah I've been about eight
years now live in a clean lifestyle you
know so I think the rest of the sports
are kind of follow suit and a lot of
guys do don't get me wrong I'm still
around
you know this system is so much a
background where they're very
professional very regimented the guys
who don't do it they just need to
tighten with a team of it in my opinion
it is a dream it's um honestly didn't
even expect it every day is a bonus like
I really meant it when I said after
winning on top there's like two mountain
stages back to back that that's just why
it's just insane like it doesn't happen
you know it's like so anything after
that is a bonus for me each time was
just being this overwhelming emotion
when you roll on social media it's just
absolutely just packed the Jets fly over
and it's just it's just it's incredible
also what it signifies the end of the
end of such a such a tough battle to get
there and rolling in and yellow is an
extremely professional feeling just to
top it off obviously whether the score
here was just like incredible life
sometimes dreams do come true and I
suppose today on a purely selfish thing
and then even just fielding it a short
leg you know with the crowd singing what
the barmy army song it's just you know
it's what it's what you play your sport
I suppose occasionally for those little
selfish moments and that was
it's frightening you could be his big
brother but you're not actually going
self yeah I think everybody will have
worked out now who are you and why are
you dressed like Gareth Southgate well
my name's Neil Rowe I'm from Surrey I'm
just a regular fan for England up this
is my fifth World Cup supporting the
boys people have been telling me for
about 20 years I'm a bit of as gasps
Gareth Southgate look-alike and now he's
got this stuff a look I thought well
I'll put down my local department store
and get the waistcoat and see what
happens and of course when he first
started you were Gareth Southgate you
missed a penalty
now you're Gareth Southgate who's got us
further in a World Cup than anybody else
for 30 years it's amazing how the wheel
has turned the positivity has changed
he's such an outward confident looking
guy and that's it in the whole spirit of
the nation and eurya he was a negative
now he's difficult
[Music]
families of people who are on board a
Malaysian airliner which went missing
four years ago say they're frustrated an
investigation into the disappearance has
revealed nothing new
Calvin shims wife Christine tom was a
member of the cabin crew difficult
because um you know we have to live by
not knowing you know why has my wife
gone missing you know no answer you know
we don't even know who where is the
wreckage yeah I think it's I just simply
can't describe the difficulties what do
you need to happen now to at least try
and help ease some of that pain I need I
need them I need a government to
proactively looking for clues and
continue the search many people might
have just thought it's too painful for
four years we're not getting any answers
what keeps you going you know we really
really mean it closer
you know I can't even tell my children
you know what has happened to the mother
we can't even have a proper you know
ceremony or you know a proper place you
know for
to remember you know my children's
mother so that is really difficult you
know what do Jacob Riis MOG Jon Bon Jovi
and Goldie Hawn all have in common well
they've all join me for K meets where we
delve a little deeper
how are you done nice to be a galaxy I'm
Kay do you immediately know I've missed
the mark many times and and some for the
better and some not you know I mean I
walked out of the room and thought
living on a prayer was okay that's okay
you know maybe we give it to this
soundtrack that was in and I was laughed
at you know Ritchie looked at me and he
said you're crazy because it was so new
it was so different
it was so such a unique song it didn't
sound like anything on the radio what
makes you so successful I think that the
most successful turn band ever oh I
don't know that's true you know the
Rolling Stones are the bar for
everything I hope someday they'll
gracefully retire for one reason
at least I'll know where the end zone is
you know as long as they're there
performing it at such a high level in
every way selling tickets and performing
as great as they do they showed me where
the end the game is but he's 20 years
older than I am and still the best
frontman in the business I was told that
I'm doing an interview with you is like
a therapy session as opposed to oh my
god does it offend you when people still
sort of think of you as that sort of
ditzy image now if I can bring any joy
to anyone it might be the greatest gift
I was given I think it's a gift I don't
even know if it comes out of me but I I
feel honored I feel respectful of it and
there's nothing better nothing better
than watching people laugh
taking free smoke thanks very much
indeed for
welcoming into your beautiful home do
you want to be Prime Minister no I like
being a member of parliament for Northey
sunset which of your principles are you
most prepared to compromise it's a
really interesting question because it
gets to the heart of politics I think
it's important to have principles to set
them out to be clear to the electorate
as to what they are but to recognize
that you cannot take your principles
endlessly to their logical conclusion
because you may end up doing harm at the
end of the process ladies and gentlemen
the President of the United States
Donald J Trump
[Music]
thank you very much everybody yes go
ahead please
this is the one that was nodding with
every nice thing I said so watch this
question it's a habit of mine how does
Peter know with whom Hanna Thomas Peter
from Sky News
okay good sky congratulations on the
purchase nothing to do with me I hope
you benefited go ahead are you at all
concerned the message that has been send
it being sent to the women who are
watching this when you use language like
con job I think I've used much worse
language in my life than con job that's
like probably the nicest phrase I've
ever used
I mean I'm job it is it's a con job you
know confidence it's a confidence sure
but they should it's a con job I the
Democrats they know it what about the
message they did the same thing with a
Russian investigation they can try to
convince people that I had something to
do with Russia
there was no collusion think of it I'm
in Wisconsin I'm in Michigan I say gee
we're not doing well I won both those
states we're not doing well let me call
the Russians to help does anybody really
believe that it's a con job
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you